it's total chaos during one wild food
fight
these diners threw all sorts of things
at each other not just fists look at
those kitty high chairs it happened at a
golden corral buffet and grill in bucks
county pennsylvania the only thing that
would have made that funnier if there
was a kid inside the [__] kitty yeah
[Music]
there's a kid in the seat
that'd be funny you know what made you
think of when you did that
that's the kid in the chair
watch as this guy tosses a chair this
knucklehead lifts a heavy table until a
female employee wrestles it out of his
hands police tell us 40 individuals were
involved so what caused the melee it
reportedly began after a man got angry
when someone behind him in line got his
stake first when he asked for it rare
that's when food and furniture started
flying
we've seen pandemonium at all you can
eat buffets before things turned violent
in new york city when there weren't
enough crab legs to go around i think
you could say that they've all got a
little
crabby
[Laughter]
you could tell that they wanted to get
there early and get their food first
they wanted a leg up
jesus christ
[Laughter]
that reminds me of back in the days
uh that place closed and reopened it's
in the chinatown
and it's called
dynasty the dynasty dynasty that looks
like that that's nasty nasty yeah you
dying nasty over there it's normally
dynasty dynasty but i mean
i don't know everybody every time i went
there it was a different accent because
it was all different asian people
working there so they said it a
different way anyways all that to say we
went there and and yo
it's on youtube actually you can look it
up what happened it's food fight oh yeah
plates
table chairs why
i don't know why that's the thing we
don't know why but that's it i find that
fascinating with these buffets how like
aggressive people get you have this like
buffet which is like
you pay twenty dollars you can get all
you can eat
yeah but sometimes i don't know
but they they run out sometimes but my
whole point is like there's still a
scarcity mindset yeah
get your [__] together so to me
to me
dynasty so
so to me i find it so fascinating that
looking at these buffets people have a
scarcity mindset you have all this
opulence all this food access and if
people can't get their steak or their
crab legs they lose their [__] minds
that's not even just in the that's not
just in the the
the buffets
remember what happened when the popeyes
had that sandwich
it happened it happened at popeyes and
people went crazy people i feel like
that's an american thing more than
anything though yeah you're not really
yeah someone's gonna see that here but
yeah yeah they go crazy
what is what is happening here like what
what what compels these people to pull
out like weapons on like fast food
restaurants or through soup in people's
faces like i feel like such crazy
behavior and here's the crazy part one
person doesn't get their steak so they
mad
and then 40 people fight no because it's
one person you're not alone right right
so then
it's just like a a
snowball effect like basically what
happened is that
you don't get your [__] so you pissed
off then you get pushed then you throw
your [__] then other person throw the
[__] someone receives some [__] it's
like yo mind your [__] you get a hit
you get not they family of that person
that didn't get the steak gets involved
the family of the other person got to
get up do you know
i gotta you know we bout about it so we
have to and then after that the person
the family of the person that receives
some [__] that's fine he's like yo uncle
tate has a problem everybody jumps on
and that's what happens yeah do you have
a cat
yeah you do i do have a cat
not your girl [__] like an actual cat
i know you're trying to be clever that's
what i was asking my girl has a cat
a hypoallergenic yeah that's why no he
doesn't have any he doesn't lose his uh
that's fur no that's not fair what is
that
that looks like cat hair bro no that's
funky out here
because i never seen you with yeah i
think you got cat hair on you bro
now i'm allergic to the cats that's why
but that one is hyper living i'm
allergic to cats so maybe you were
another cat are you you're allergic to
can you had a cat i got a lot of [__]
it's impossible because i've been having
that cat since
i know there's only only this wrong cats
but nothing like the fight at the golden
corral which in this case looked more
like the okay crowd
shout outs to you that was a strong play
on words strong you know listen you know
welcome to the club
local authorities are investigating the
incident thankfully no serious injuries
have been reported you did all this
because you didn't get some food but now
nobody gets to eat yeah so what you did
yeah obviously it's kind of kind of
embarrassing to see adults act like kids
like that
but yeah you didn't get your french
fries like breath just eat something
else
but i don't even like the ideas of like
all you can eat buffets they kind of
make me feel weird just seeing all the
food waste and just don't eat at my face
why tell me i stopped that time ago i've
only been once i've i've heard a lot too
many stories of people that work there
okay well what do you hear go tell
people the way like if the things fall
on the floor they pick it up they put it
right back in the thing go serve it to
people the way the way things are not
maintained it's high volume you
understand whenever there's high volume
things are not as well maintained you
know what i mean whenever you go for
example you go on a plane don't take the
coffee on the plane don't take the
coffee why because they don't wash that
[__]
i have a coffee machine at home i have
to wash it every month
i have to descale it and do all these
stuff they don't do that stuff they
don't have time to do that so buffets
no
that's not where i go there's other
places to get my food other than buffets
i've been to buffets but
i choose to
stay away hey
hey
don't go to buffets